and what do you make of that lenders
being too complacent well what I'd say
is we we are not complacent I heard Alec
Ferguson once they complacence is a
disease and so we should all avoid that
at all costs I think that it's really
important that the Bank of England are
making the comments that they are
interest rates are obviously low wages
are flat and as a result people are keen
to borrow more and we just all have to
make sure that people can afford to pay
back what they do borrow and a purging
money we're very very focused on making
sure we lend responsibly to our
customers and they understand what
they've got and so far you know that's
going very well it's very interesting
the Bank of England's prudential
regulatory arm recently decided against
capping effective interest rates on
cards so I mean they could have done
that could they if they were really
worried I think that if you remember a
couple of years ago there was a concern
about the by solute housing market in
the Bank of England intervened the PRA
intervened just to say that they had
these concerns and often that's I
suspect what it takes in order to get
all of the banks really focused on are
we doing the right thing do we think
we've got a problem here and so I think
that their comments that they're making
are well timed and you know definitely
in a place that means that all of the
banks I'm sure will be looking at the
quality of their lending in the way in
which they lend we always look at that
I'm sure others do too today
particularly after the speech made last
night
are you actually turning away a lot of
credit applicants then from our point of
view we accept customers that meet our
credit criteria and then we do turn away
those that don't I mean other banks do
offer customers a different deal perhaps
a more expensive deal but from my point
of view we think that it is responsible
to say to customers this is the product
and this is the hurdle that you have to
achieve in order to get it and if you
don't then it's probably not right for
you so what about this warning that
you've issued on the housing market
today I mean it's it's rattled some some
of your investors today hasn't it
well do you - it wasn't meant to be a
warning on their housing market at all
from our point of view we were just
giving a balance that looked to what's
been an excellent first half so we've
had the best ever half year for
mortgages i'm intermedia business is
strong we've got new products and so
from our perspective all is good the
housing market certainly flattens
slightly growing on last year but we're
just looking to the future and saying
you know we do say that there's some
tempering of house
and consumers we think just need to
think about that as they take out
mortgages so they don't borrow too much
you've actually said I think house price
weaknesses in certain regions is that
London you're talking about well I think
we've seen a lot of press and media
comments that London house prices are
certainly flattening and I'm sure
that'll be the case given some of the
uncertainties around brexit particularly
if people from overseas aren't buying
properties in London anymore now you
know many local Londoners might say that
that's a great thing to happen so we're
certainly looking to the future with
continued confidence just aware as
everybody should be that things can
change so your share prices off
something like nine percent this evening
because of these comments allegedly
you've been buying shares this evening
you'll notice that well I mean you know
we've got at best ever result we've got
a really strong business and we look to
the future with confidence given that
we're so confident about that outlook
and the quality of our business and
given where the share price is I'm
delighted to be able to do that wish I
could have done some more to be honest
now separately you've been at the
forefront of the campaign to get more
women into senior roles in the finance
industry which has a shocking record on
the gender pay gap what did you make of
those numbers that the BBC published
last week well I mean I think that
regardless of what we think about the
numbers which weren't good I think the
fact that they're out in the open and
public will make a difference and so you
know I think that it should be a
requirement for the gender pay gap to be
published for all organizations and we
published ours it's not as good as I
want it to be but at least it's out
there so that we can start to make a
difference TSB have done the same thing
and I applaud them for it but not very
many organizations have and I think that
until organisations are required to
disclose their gender pay gap people
will hide behind that you know that veil
if you like let's make sure that all
organisations disclose it and then it we
can change it